[Applause]
[Music]
where is my president
in little more than 10 days the republic
of afghanistan collapsed and the taliban
seized power in the entire country only
one province the province of pangea
today the focus of a budding resistance
managed to avoid the avalanche the
taliban advance was so swift that as we
could all see live and direct they
managed to put the very american forces
that had the mission of commanding the
evacuation against the wall at times it
was total chaos
after 20 years thousands and thousands
of lost lives and a cost of over 2.2
trillion dollars according to estimates
from brown university the dramatic
images of the us withdrawal from saigon
were being repeated though on this
occasion to a much greater extent how
could this happen how could the taliban
seize power so quickly
american troops cannot and should not be
fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan troops are not willing to
fight for themselves joe biden president
of the united states
president biden lied and must be ashamed
we lost 70 000 men in war we have
carried out 95 of all operations since
2014. just when we were clearing farah
the air support supply chain and our
communication were suspended sarfaraz
afghan commando
they tied our hands behind our backs and
sold the homeland damn ghani and his
gang we will liberate afghanistan from
these terrorists history will judge gani
the lover of their gang general
bismillah muhammadi minister of defense
of the islamic republic of afghanistan
[Music]
afghan security forces were supposed to
be ready after 20 years of training and
preparation by international troops
after u.s spending of more than 80
billion dollars and with supposedly 350
000 units between the army and
militarized police the republic of
afghanistan was supposed to resist at
least that's the story we were told
23rd july 2018 we are on the right track
the afghan military and police are
demonstrating their will to succeed john
w nicholson jr four-star general and
commander-in-chief of u.s forces in
afghanistan from 2016 to 2018.
we provided our afghan partners with all
the tools let me emphasize all the tools
training and equipment of any modern
military we provided advanced weaponry
joe biden
but what happened to an army that since
2014 has been responsible for more than
95 of military operations to suddenly
dissolve like a mere sugar cube what
happened in afghanistan so the taliban
was able to seize power again with so
little resistance why on earth did
afghanistan fall on visualpolitik we
have prepared a trilogy of videos to try
to understand this whole story the past
present and future of the united
states's longest war of the latest
military defeat of the great american
power
losing a war is never joyful but no one
imagined seeing the images of defeat
flight and lack of order we have all
witnessed images that will forever be a
heavy burden of neglect defeat and
mismanagement for joe biden's
administration
there was nothing that i or anyone else
saw that indicated the collapse of this
government in 11 days general mark
milley chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff of the united states in this first
video we're going to focus on the four
key factors the four hypotheses that
explain the overwhelming taliban victory
there are four scenarios that have
occurred and that are complementary to
each other what we do not know with
certainty is the exact weight that each
of them has had in the afghan debacle
but we do know that all of them have
contributed decisively to what has
happened
we were betrayed we were told a peace
agreement is reached a transitional
government is being formed stop fighting
retreat to your bases then we were
ordered to hand over everything to the
taliban i will rate more as i am able to
remember another 911 is coming i'm
devastated safaris afghan commando this
is how afghanistan fell listen up
the betrayal of doha
[Music]
imagine you are the president of the
united states and after 20 years of
combat thousands upon thousands of
casualties and formidable expense you
are bogged down in a war you know you
can never win or rather that the cost
and sacrifice of trying to win is too
high
i remember afghanistan as a dusty beige
nightmare of a place full of proud brave
people who did not want us there laura
jadid journalist and u.s veteran of the
afghan war
imagine that at that precise moment you
are presented with a plan mr president
we have the formula to escape the
hornet's nest we have a plan to avoid
new casualties to stop the economic
drain that war entails to prevent new
terrorist groups from running wild and
at the same time to possibly achieve
some geoeconomic gains sounds good
doesn't it
well now imagine that this plan consists
specifically of making a pact with the
taliban and even facilitating their
access to power yes yes that's what i
said there's
ongoing talks with the taliban and
hopefully those will be successful we
don't know if events unfolded according
to this particular script but that is in
practice exactly what happened
[Music]
in 2018 the trump administration asked
pakistan to release mullah abdulgani
baradar and u.s secretary of state mike
pompeo traveled and met with him to
begin negotiations i met with um
the current political leader of the
taliban the result was that in february
2020 the doha agreement was signed an
agreement that the afghan government of
ghani strongly opposed although
ultimately to no avail the agreement
established a timetable for the
withdrawal of international troops the
release of thousands and thousands of
taliban prisoners and the reduction of
airstrikes and also of u.s military
operations all this in exchange for the
taliban not attacking international
troops undertaking not to harbor
terrorist groups and negotiating a
political solution to the conflict with
the afghan government we agreed to the
release of over
taliban prisoners
most of them guilty of serious crimes
against humanity
we've paid a heavy cost for peace
and taken serious risks
but we've seen
unfortunately no dividends yet
these are the details that are known
because much of the agreement remains
and will remain secret in other words
the americans negotiated the roadmap for
the future of afghanistan not with the
afghan government which was not even
present at the table but with the
taliban
[Music]
the doha agreement bought the taliban a
one-year reprieve they were able to
regroup to plan to strengthen their
supply lines to have freedom of movement
without fear of us bombing andrew
watkins member of the u.s institute of
peace and in a way it makes sense think
about it
beyond the moral question it raises if
you make a pact with the taliban and
make sure that they do not give shelter
to terrorist groups that could attack
then it's the icing on the cake you
won't have any more casualties you'll be
able to leave the country without al
qaeda or any other group having free
reign you'll be able to focus your
attention and resources on your real
priority the pacific and the containment
of china and if on top of that they come
to power then well then it could even
open the door to certain opportunities
let me explain
afghanistan is a country very rich in
the minerals most coveted by the
technology industry minerals such as
copper lithium cobalt niobium rare
earths as well as gold and uranium in
fact according to a pentagon report
cited by the new york times in 2010
afghanistan has the potential to become
the saudi arabia of lithium
and not only that there are also
projects such as the tapi gas pipeline a
1127 mile that's
1814 kilometers pipeline project that
could carry natural gas from
turkmenistan to pakistan india and china
a project that is owned by u.s oil
company chevron and that could alleviate
china's dependence on russian natural
gas while reducing iran's strategic
importance well in february 2021 in a
visit apparently coordinated by the
united states itself the taliban visited
turkmenistan and pledged to protect this
project because the pipeline has to pass
through afghanistan
and the problem so far is that in order
to exploit minerals or build energy
networks you need political stability as
long as you are on a war footing with
the taliban nothing can be done but the
doha agreement was an opportunity to
leave once and for all a cia style
operation
and that for many analysts is what
explains why the united states would
practically stop attacking the taliban
despite the fact that they have stepped
up their operations against the afghan
army and institutions to the point that
the un described 2020 as the most
violent year in the country since
records began sure at first glance the
doha agreements may explain the overall
scenario but it's not enough to fully
understand why on earth the afghan army
dissolved so quickly it's something that
even caught the u.s government itself
completely off guard although the truth
is that the almost total reduction of
air strikes the withdrawal of air force
contractors and the consequence
demoralization of the troops played a
key role listen up
looting as the norm
[Music]
it is not the first time that there has
been a disbandment of the made in the
usa afghan army in the fall of 2015 in
kunduz province an offensive by 500
taliban defeated 3 000 afghan soldiers
and police and captured a provincial
capital for the first time then in
helmand province some 1 800 taliban
defeated nearly 4 500 soldiers and
police
they ran they had everything they needed
troops weapons ammunition and they gave
up omar john commander of the afghan
army
[Music]
an important note let us make no mistake
this is not to say that the afghan army
has not made efforts over the years the
afghans have borne the brunt of the
conflict the army and police alone have
accumulated around 70 000 casualties the
fact is that both demotivation and
shortage of materials were the order of
the day but how could an army in which
so much money has been invested more
than 80 billion dollars in almost 15
years have so many problems well one
reason lies in the kind of military the
united states has designed an army
assembled in its own image and likeness
deployed throughout the country by means
of a remote network of outposts and
bases a network completely dependent on
a complex logistical and support system
made up of planes and helicopters that
the afghans were simply incapable of
managing
when kunduz province fell to the taliban
many soldiers were killed we were
surrounded there was no air support in
the last minutes our commander told us
that there was nothing they could do for
us and that it was better to flee they
all abandoned the war and escaped abdul
kudus 29 year old afghan soldier
but above all it has to do with what is
perhaps the most striking afghan
characteristic of recent decades massive
corruption and you see despite the
enormous amounts of money spent by the
americans afghan soldiers had derisory
salaries they could go months without
being paid and even ammunition was
scarce so when the taliban showed up
they would pull a pablo escobar plata o
plomo silva or lead however they
surrendered and received supplies and
even women and some money or they would
all be killed in fact it is believed
that the taliban have been cutting deals
with military officials for many months
now
no region fell as a result of war but as
a result of psychological warfare abbas
tawakoli commander of the 217th afghan
army corps
everyone just handed in their weapons
and fled we didn't get any help from the
central government so the district fell
without any fighting rahimula a 25 year
old afghan soldier
the point is that supplies were scarce
because probably a good part of the
money spent by the americans ended up in
places like dubai or qatar for example
ahmed zia masood a former afghan vice
president was accused of taking more
than 50 million dollars to dubai where
he lived in a luxurious mansion and
drove around in rolls-royces another
example well check it out
[Music]
top military and government officials
lied about the numbers of soldiers and
pocketed the money from the phantom
payroll one day the americans who were
funding the payroll of over 300 000
realised that the real number was barely
more than 250 000 if that and of the
legitimate paychecks many high
commanders and warlords usually kept a
good part of it making the soldiers even
more miserable in the end they had to
set up an electronic payment system and
still the problems persisted
but it wasn't just a question of those
at the top not at all corruption was
widespread after all if you gave a
soldier who is paid barely 200 a month
when he is paid that is equipment worth
thousands of dollars the result is no
wonder the black market that's exactly
what happened when the pentagon tried to
equip the afghan army with night fission
goggles they kept disappearing and so
did vehicle components and so did
weapons so did ammunition so did fuel so
did many supplies all in all the
americans were paying the bills and
control was conspicuous by its absence
in addition soldiers and policemen were
in many cases dedicated to collecting
bribes at checkpoints causing a large
part of society to have little
confidence in them for being soft the
police became the most hated institution
in the country because the taliban did
the same thing but only once not like
the police who constantly demanded
payments
the taliban principle is once you pay
the tax bribe they give you a receipt
that works all over the country and you
will not be asked to pay the tax bribe
again police officers on the other hand
do not issue receipts for the bribes
they extort ahmad saeed azimiyan deputy
head of the chamber of commerce in harap
province
so if you have an army that is largely
poorly trained poorly equipped lacking
in everything and unmotivated the result
is exactly what we have seen when the
taliban arrived and threatened them many
forces fled or changed sides handing
over their us-made military equipment to
the taliban a phenomenon that only
worsened when they no longer had the
support of the americans they weren't
fighting for a cause and everything
around them was corrupt why risk their
lives this factor my friends decimated
the afghan forces to levels that were
actually far below the 167 000 troops
the army was supposed to have some
sources suggest that at the moment of
truth there were barely 50 000
ill-equipped soldiers ready to fight but
scattered around the country without any
strategy the outcome is one we all know
by now but there are still two other
hypotheses two factors that we have to
consider listen up
fatal errors and pakistan
it's clear that the united states has
made many mistakes in afghanistan
perhaps the most significant of all has
been the failure to create an army and
security forces capable of defeating the
taliban and here many analysts point to
a very specific issue the time it took
to assemble an afghan army because
setting up an army and a police force
from scratch is not at all easy and
doing it in afghanistan and on top of
that suffering a high personnel rotation
due to the casualty suffered makes
everything much more complicated
we don't have to teach american soldiers
to obey the law not to take bribes to
respect human rights they come into our
force having internalized those things
already we try to create militaries in
our image and that's often not congruent
with the political and social
circumstances in which those forces are
operating michael nagata former
commander of u.s special operations
command central
the fact is that when the united states
invaded the country and defeated the
taliban for a few years there was a
certain calm but obsessed with iraq and
with reducing committed spending
president bush and his defense secretary
donald rumsfeld made what have come to
be seen as two big mistakes firstly they
rejected the offer of many taliban
leaders to negotiate a political
solution and secondly they insisted that
afghanistan maintained ridiculous
security forces barely 50 000 men to
control a huge country
[Music]
in addition the pentagon wanted to
reduce costs so they insisted on keeping
salaries and any expenses derived from
the maintenance of the troops low when
rumsfeld left in 2006 and the taliban
intensified their offensives barely 26
000 afghan soldiers had been trained and
equipped the decision turned out to be
very costly because the afghan army's
shortcomings had to be covered for all
these years by american troops whose
deployment costs exceeded a million
dollars per unit per year the worst
thing is that the afghan army never
managed to consolidate and considers
that her modern army is not much more
than a soldier carrying a weapon for
example it lacks mechanics of all kinds
quartermasters and medical professionals
and there is none of that in afghanistan
basically the bush and rumsfeld
decisions were a waste of the best years
while fueling the corruption we have
already mentioned and finally there is
the pakistan theory
you see many afghans and analysts
believe that the pakistani army has
trained equipped provided logistics and
even loaned officers consultants and
troops to the taliban in other words the
afghan army has actually faced a force
that was largely trained by a much
larger and more professional army but
why would pakistan support the taliban
well mainly to control afghanistan and
to avoid indian influence in addition
there is also the issue of the tapi
pipeline that could one day supply the
country with gas
well these are the four factors that we
have to take into account in order to
understand the rapid fall of afghanistan
all in all the images we have seen are a
huge stain on the management of the
biden administration the chaos the
tension lack of coordination the
disaster the taliban have even had
within their reach the possibility of
turning 2500 american soldiers into
hostages all they would have to do is to
attack the runway and prevent planes
from taking off and landing if they have
not done so it is perhaps because they
want government more than war so what
can we expect from the taliban now what
future does afghanistan face will the
resistance be able to make life
impossible for the taliban that is
something that we'll be delving into in
two upcoming videos here on
visualpolitik so don't forget to
subscribe and now if you found this
video interesting then please give it a
like once again thank you very much for
being there all the best and see you
next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
media.com
podcast see you there